Hi, and welcome to the Neil
Ashton Podcast.
In each episode, we explained
some of the fascinating ways
that science and engineering are
changing the world around us.
We talk to leading engineers
from elite level sports like
cycling and Formula One to some
of the world's top academics to
understand how fluid dynamics,
machine learning and supercomputing
are bringing in a new era of
discovery.
We also hear some of their life
stories, their career advice,
the lessons they've learned on
the way that I hope will be
helpful to you too.
So sit back and enjoy this
episode.
Hi, and welcome back to the Neil
Ashton Podcast.
So today's episode is just me
and I wanted to go through what
I thought were five of the top
important trends in CFD, let's
say over the now and over the
next 5 or so years.
I'd love to know whether you
agree with what I'm going to
say.
These are sort of more, I guess,
high level trends rather than
getting into the, you know,
specific details.
Very happy to do an episode
diving a bit deeper into one of
these, but I thought I would
maybe stimulate some discussion
and get you thinking about some
of these.
And I have to also give a, a bit
of, I think that I'm coming from
a certain angle here.
I guess my experiences in
everything I've done will bias
me.
And I just want to admit that
that bias.
I come more from an external
aerodynamics background in terms
of CFD, you know, I currently
work for a cloud computing
company.
I'm obviously going to see
things through the conversations
I have and the lens I see, but
I'd like to think that I see
enough of what's going on in
different sort of verticals and
and different areas that gives
me a reasonable understanding of
what's going on.
So yeah, let's see if you agree.
So yeah, five things that I
think are important for CFD over
the next five years or so, not
necessarily in chronological or
like in in important order, but
number one for me is GPUs and ARM-based processors.
Why do I say this?
It was the case when I let's say
back in 2013 or something like
that, I remember going to a Parallel
CFD conference.
So this they still run parallel
CFD.
It's a great conference to go to
sort of that blend between high
performance computing and CFD.
And I remember there like 10
years ago, this was at Barcelona
Supercomputing Center, really
great venue right on the
Las Ramblas strip.
Anyone who's listening who went
there will know it was a great conference organised by the
Barcelona people and I remember
seeing presentations showing
about GPUs and I can't believe
that was like 10 years ago now.
And there was a real sense in
the room of I remember someone
said that you can only get good
performance out of it if you
write the code from scratch.
I remember someone saying that
and there being a bit of a
debate and I remember there
being sort of sensational
claims, you know, that GPUs are
this much faster and, and a
little bit of a, oh, you know,
ignore them sort of thing.
And obviously at that time
NVIDIA was doing a lot of work
to invest in in CUDA and sort of
giving funding to research
groups.
And I remember seeing this and
yeah, it, it, it was, it
registered on my radar.
But a lot of people were, were,
were debating whether it could
be possible, whether there'd be
enough memory on the GPUs.
Was it really possible to
rewrite a code?
You know, people said they had
millions of lines of code.
I'm never going to be able to do
this.
Fast forward to now and I would
say for me it's incredibly clear
that GPUs are going to be the
the dominant computing platform
for CFD.
But as I'll say later, things
move very slowly, especially in
industrial CFD.
And so the adoption is going to
take time.
But I have seen enough to make
me believe that and I'll give several reasons.
One, there are published
publications out there that show
it.
I've certainly showed it in
public settings and the ISVs and software companies have
done it.
And in fact just for AutoCFD,
this automotive workshop that
that I created back in 2018 in
19 with Gary Page at Loughborough
and now it's in its fourth
edition.
I think the slides are now up
and the video is on the website.
So if if you go to AutoCFD.org
and you scroll down and you go
to the HPC presentation, Herbert
Owen from Barcelona
Supercomputing Centre did a
great job of taking everybody's
submissions from CPU and GPU and
then looking at what type of
GPU, what type of CPU, and doing
a really good, good job of
looking at several different
metrics.
So the speed, you know, per
degree of freedom, per time
step, looking at the cost.
So we took a sort of a notional
cost from AWS.
It could have been any cloud
provider.
It's just, you know, it's the
only way of getting an actual
price for these things because
obviously the cloud gives you
the all in cost.
Whereas if you were to find a
website that would give you just
the sort of the GPU or the CPU
that wouldn't be the actual
entire cost including the power
and the the network etcetera.
And what it showed is that for
external aerodynamics of cars,
GPUs were more cost effective,
at least 2×, 3×, 5× or 10×.
It depended on the code or even
cheaper than an equivalent
CPU at the scale that it was
being run for a realistic
problem, not sort of toy
benchmark problem.
And they were faster, but that's
a slightly harder one because it
depends what the parallel
scaling of the code is and and
you know, how many CPUs or GPUs
do you throw at it.
Whereas the cost, you know,
obviously it's going to change a
little bit in a nonlinear regime.
You know, if you're really badly
scaling, the cost is going to go
up relative.
But essentially what it showed
was the cost.
Now I have repeated this same
thing myself personally with
startup codes and ISV codes.
And I have seen the same thing,
which means that for a certain
classification of workloads and
I can only speak what I've seen
and personally, so I'll speak
more, let's say in plane design,
car design, but I've seen it and
I believe it to be so in other
areas.
It is.
You're ultimately going to run
your simulation cheaper on a GPU
than a CPU.
So forget about speed, it's
going to be cheaper.
And why is it cheaper?
Ultimately, these are things
like power efficiency, energy
efficiency.
So even though the GPU looks
more expensive to buy for one
node, when you actually look at
how long does that node need to
run for, you know, it's easier
like I said, to calculate with
cloud because of pay-as-you-go
pricing, it is cheaper, and
as soon as something is cheaper
economically it makes sense it
is going to gain widespread
industrial adoption.
Now where's the nuance to this
is what GPU there is in some
ways a divergent, well, not
divergent, but there is a, there
is a market for machine learning
GPUs with a particular focus on,
you know, certain precision,
lower precision, ultimately, than most CFD codes would need.
And so you're going, you know,
from A100s to H100s,
H200s, etcetera to
Blackwell that are driving up,
you know, more and more
performance.
And CFD absolutely can take
advantage of that performance.
And it's great because there's
a, we can jump on the bandwagon
essentially of machine learning.
But there is also another
classification of cards that
quite often are more designed
for inference, but these sort of
L40S- or RTX-type cards that
actually have a very, very good
price performance.
So that raw performance may not
be as high as those sort of more
top end GPUs, but for CFD, they
actually are often when you do
the maths, even better price
performance.
And that's what we showed at AutoCFD.
Now the reason I'm saying that I
think the GPUs will become the
main is because if you look at
the trajectory of GPU
development in terms of
generation after generation
improvement and you look at the
same on the CPU front.
I think it's hard to deny that
again, because of the investment
from machine learning, there is
a much greater boost in
performance from generation to
generation on GPUs than there is
on the x86 CPUs.
And the fact that there is
rising competition now between
NVIDIA and AMD.
And also maybe there's room for
more, you know, startup or
emergent technologies that's
only going to drive more and
more focus.
Now, I say ARM64 as well
because that has emerged as a,
at first maybe more of a niche
architecture that was harder to
get people to convince.
And I know speaking from being at AWS, we have our Graviton processors
and you know, we struggled for
people to think, well, why
should I bother to port my code, you know, to ARM.
But now with more and more
companies with, you know, the
other hyperscalers also releasing them, and obviously NVIDIA,
with the Grace system sort of
linking the two, there is far
more and there's far more reason
for a major code to port to it.
And as soon as that happens, the
ecosystem jumps behind it.
And again, the the power
efficiency and the performance
numbers make it extremely
attractive.
That's not to say that people
aren't going to be running on,
you know, AMD or Intel CPUs, of
course.
And as I said, the CFD market
and engineering in general or
any use of CFD tends to be slow.
And so if from 2013 to now
there's been that sort of
movement, it's not going to
happen overnight.
But what I can see is every
single one of the major ISVs has
or is porting their codes.
The issue is that not all the
features in the codes are
available.
So yeah, some of the multi
physics, some of the options are
not yet done.
So you may not be able to use
the GPU version today because it
may not have the feature that
you need if you're doing some
more sophisticated modeling, but
it's probably on the road map.
And more importantly is the
codes.
And these are more the startups like Luminary Cloud, Volcano Platforms or
Flexcompute.
And there are others who are
really who have really focused
on GPU-native code.
And in the case of, for example,
Volcano Platforms taking advantage of GPUs
by designing for GPUs, Cartesian methods and immersed
boundaries, etcetera.
And there are others as well
doing this and, you know, hiring
super talented people who have
come out of universities and
institutes with a deep, deep
understanding of how GPUs work.
Programming it from the base
from the beginning with the
latest, you know, programming
languages and and and knowledge
of how to extract the maximum
performance is really only going
to accelerate it further.
And I'll talk about this in the
last point.
This emergence of new startup codes is also invigorating
because simply, if you look
through the eyes of a commercial
company, why change?
If you are the main company,
main ISV provider, why would you
change?
You're earning good money from
your licenses.
You are you've got customers and
if your competitors are all
basically doing the same thing,
so none of them, let's say five
years ago, six years ago, OK,
none of them are moving to GPUs.
Well, why should we spend all
the effort doing?
Is it really that important?
Is it really going to make a
difference?
Are we going to lose customers
from it?
And of course the technical
reasons, you know, was there
enough memory?
Is there enough performance to
gain from it?
The one thing that drives a
company to change is
competition.
And so with the emergence of
alternative providers, many of
whom who are specifically
marketing their code around
being GPU performance, it forces
companies to do it.
And you've seen that with, you
know, with Ansys sort of
rewriting their their solver and
you know, showing a very, very
strong performance.
And at the AutoCFD workshop, we
saw pretty much all of the ISVs
specifically focus on their GPU
performance and their speed,
which three years ago was not
the case.
So everything feels like the
right momentum.
Now the tricky thing is the
whole ecosystem needs to to
work.
So is are the third party
meshing tools going to work on GPUs?
And I mention this because we
get to another point, which is
around the sort of high
performance computing, because
obviously if you're going to
procure a cluster, if one code
works amazing on GPUs, but all the rest are on CPUs, you then
need to figure out, well, what's
my ratio of compute options to
buy?
And, and so this links it to one
of the third points later that
the other reason for GPUs is
national supercomputers.
OK, what do I mean by that?
Well, if you are, let's say, in
Spain and you want to show to
your government that you as a
country are pushing the
boundaries of science, of R&D,
and you're attracting
entrepreneurialism,
supercomputing has traditionally
been a great way.
It's a sort of, you know, a big
lighthouse.
And the US is a more obvious one
for that.
But I'll pick a country other
than the US, your supercomputer
obviously a lot of that is then
based on its performance and the
top 500 list is often you know
the metric like what is the
total performance of the system.
You know the the sort of exaflop
race to try and get an exascale computing.
A lot of this has driven to
GPUs because the total
performance of the system is
much higher for a given power
output with GPUs, and arguably
it is also newer technology.
So more novelty, more
differentiation can enable
better science because there's
more, you know, throughput can
be produced.
And secondly, even more
importantly, secondly, is
because of machine learning,
because machine learning is now
being integrated and is a key
research topic as well.
And so if you're a national
supercomputing centre, you want
to be able to do ML research and
you want GPUs.
What does that mean?
It means that if you're an
academic and you want access to
these supercomputers to do your
research, like people do in
Spain, let's say, you will have
to write your code to fit on the
system.
And so sure enough, that
motivated researchers in Spain.
And now let's broaden it to the
UK, to the US, to port their
code to GPUs.
Essentially, they can run on the
systems that they need to.
And so there's been a push and
pull.
There's been a push because they
think it is the right
architecture to deliver better
performance.
Or maybe that's the pull.
But there's also a push because
the system they want to run on
has GPUs.
So I should say that has also
been the drive towards GPUs.
There is a, once a decision is
made that the big supercomputers
are going to have GPUs, you
almost are then having to, well,
I'll just port my code, you know,
to, to go to it.
And so that's more the balance
to the industrial side and the
academic side, why both are now
meeting.
And again, remember, many of
these startup codes emerged out
of more academic or government
work where they had moved to
GPUs because one, they're just
more aware of the the science.
And I would say this is what
companies like NVIDIA have also
put a lot of groundwork in
investing in helping people to
understand CUDA and helping them
to port their codes.
And that has now moved through
into the startup.
And as I'll speak about later,
almost inevitably many of these
startups are going to be
acquired by the larger
companies.
There's an interesting sort of
ecosystem and flywheel effect.
So the next one is on AI/ML. And
you know, again, you're, you're
typically really for AI/ML or
you're really against it.
This tends to be the case of any
new technologies.
The reason I'm more bullish on
AI/ML and that's through my own
personal experience actually, at
least I would encourage anybody
else on, you know, looking at
code, writing code, doing
experiments, publishing,
organizing, really trying to
immerse themselves.
And I would actually make it
similar to the way that I saw
GPUs back in, let's say the 2010s, where again, I saw a
similar dynamic of some people
really being against it and
saying, oh, it's just all hype.
You know, there's no way they're
going to be able to do it.
I'm not going to be able to
port.
It's not, you know, the
technology is not going to be
there to others who are like,
it's just a matter of when I see
the AI in a similar way, but
with some more nuances, which is
what exactly can AI be used for
within CFD?
Well, the first point I would
say is the commercial pull.
And you know you may if you come
from a more pure background, you
may hate this sort of speak, but
this is just the way the world
works.
When the large ISV companies,
many of them who are
stakeholders or boards to please
people invest in their companies
in the current climate because
of perception of how much are
they embracing and leading when
it comes to innovation,
particularly around AI.
And so a major ISV has to show
to their board and stakeholders
and shareholders that they are
fully embracing and are doing
something about it.
And I would say in some ways,
many of them have had to catch
up.
Now, I don't know that, you
know, working to the companies,
maybe they've had many proposals
beforehand.
But certainly I would say the
whole ChatGPT moment has, you
know, caught some of them off
guard and made them really have
to double down and decide what
to do and what and if they can
release it.
That means that there's a lot
of sort of R&D and focus within
these major CFD and CAE companies.
But this has also fed a lot of
startup market.
So for a similar reason that
many of the startups and there
are many many to list, you know
NAVASTO, PhysicsX and
BeyondMath.
I'm probably going to insult
people by not mentioning them.
I can't think—I'll probably list
them all out: Monolith, Neural Concept.
Yeah, I can't remember.
There's, there's loads of them.
So I, I, I'm sure I'm offending
some of them.
The point is that or Key Ward as
well.
And yeah, OK, I'll try and make
sure I mention most of them so I
don't offend people.
They have got VC funding because
a lot of the VCs are seeing.
Could this be the next big
thing?
And so there are to my last count at
least 10 start-ups looking at
doing AI/ML specifically for CFD.
And quite often for things like
I spoke about car design or plane design.
The fact that they have a lot of
money does not necessarily mean
that it will turn into success,
but it does show that there's a
lot of concerted effort.
And when there are hundreds of
people or thousands of people
collectively working on this,
that often leads to advancement.
And when I talk about
advancement, I typically mean in
terms of surrogate modelling.
So what some people would call
reduced order modelling, but
obviously more sort of
sophisticated version of that
were essentially, and This is
why it's particularly
interesting from an ISV or
commercial point where you may
essentially not need the CFD solver during the solve step.
So you train a model on some
data and then once you have the
model, you do inference and
that's completely outside the
CFD code, which obviously is
worrying for an ISV that thinks
we could be losing some of our,
you know, potential license or
revenue or, you know, customers
because they could be trying to
use this other tool that we
don't have.
So and just speaking
commercially now that means
those ISVs really need to
figure out is this an important
technology that could transform?
And if so, we either need to
develop it ourselves or we need
to go and buy a start up.
And that's really the the key
thing that's driving a lot of
these companies to then, you
know, have a look at these
start-ups.
Why economically does it work as
well is because on the one hand,
the end user, just as with GPUs.
So, so what's the reason for the
end user to be interested in
AI/ML? For GPUs, the main reason was lower cost
computing and potentially faster
computing, you know, GPUs if if
the pace continues, you know,
we're going to see potential of
the next five years 5–10×
speed up in in stuff.
So it not only is a lot faster
and also talk a minute about
this leads to more high-fidelity transient methods to
become possible even in a day or
less than a day for AI/ML.
It's that the inference can be
both cheap and fast and that is
something that brings up a lot
of potential for for companies.
So for example, it means that
real time CFD has long been
spoken about and GPUs were sort
of billed as potentially
enabling real time CFD if you go
back 5-10 years ago.
But I would argue that that's
not really turned out to be the
case because some problems are
not.
They can be parallel in space,
but maybe not parallel in time.
So doesn't matter how much
compute you throw at it,
sometimes it just takes a while,
particularly for transient
methods which you may need to do
for accuracy purposes.
OK you could do maybe a RANS simulation or
lower fidelity, but truly real
time click of a button instantly
get the answer.
You have to make so many
accommodations on accuracy that
it ends up really not being
worth the sort of the balance.
The AI/ML is the interesting bit
because the inference itself
could be real time, but you
could spend a lot of money in
computing time on training a
model based on high fidelity
data that could, if the ML model
was accurate enough, give you
quite a good answer in real
time.
And so this opens up a lot of
potential, particularly in
bringing CFD closer to the
designer, closer to digital
twins, more into, you know, like
NVIDIA's doing with Omniverse,
into a sort of virtual world
where you could be simulating
things almost in real time.
The classic example is the car
designer, you know who's not a CFD specialist who wants to
draw a car, click a button, see
it, get a sense of what the drag
is and then continue iterating.
Now I should say this is not in
the short term or even probably
the medium term about replacing
high fidelity CFD.
But I do think it has a very
potentially disruptive role in
the lower fidelity conceptual
design phases that could really
be important.
And so commercially, this could
mean basically a key tool in the
market and this is driving a lot
of start-ups because there is a
sense that there could be
acquisitions or mergers from
some of the big ISVs or they
could simply become big codes.
And the CAE market is five, $10
billion at least and growing.
And it's growing because there
is a desire for digital
certification.
There's a desire to go more into
the virtual world because it's
cheaper and faster than wind-tunnel
testing or physical testing.
So now there is still, and I
want to make this very clear in
my mind, many challenges and
many areas that will most likely
change dramatically in this
space.
I do not believe that any of the
current methods published today
will be the method that we end
up using in five years time.
I could be wrong and maybe it'll
only just be iterations of it,
but the field is moving so
quickly that I just find it hard
to believe that what we have
today is the best we can do.
Essentially, and I say this
because if you look at the CFD
world, actually a lot of the
breakthroughs in terms of the
physics or the modelling were
sort of done 20 years ago.
You know, most of the wall-modelled LES
or hybrid RANS–LES or RANS modelling, it's actually 20
years old.
And what's the novel bit is more
the computer science, the use of
GPUs, etcetera.
But the actual breakthrough
modelling, mathematical
modelling was done 20-30 years
ago.
There's obviously some new
developments, but most people,
if you're using DES, you know,
what's that 2004 or something,
depending on which version
you're using of it.
If you're using k–omega SST RANS, it's 1994.
So what's that 30 years ago?
So it's a bit like going back to
1994.
The k–ω model comes out and it
gives good results.
I'm thinking that's it.
I think we're in a similar time with AI/ML: yes, there are many
startups and companies, but I
don't think the actual modelling
or the accuracy today is
anything like we'll see in the
future.
And so that means there could be
a lot of change, a lot of
disruption.
And that's why I think it's a
really important area to get
into because there's no doubt
there has still been major
issues improving scale.
Can these AI methods, you know,
work on hundreds of millions of
cell meshes?
Can they work in terms of the
accuracy?
You know, have they really shown
how accurate they are down to,
you know, a drag count
difference?
There's been a lot of studies,
but there's been limited real
concrete evidence of it away
from just sort of marketing.
And the big question, of course,
is around foundation models.
So most of what the startups and
most people who talk about it
are doing is saying, we'll take
the data you have as a company X
train a model, you train a model
essentially, and then you do
inference on it as opposed to
ChatGPT like methods that take
huge data from the Internet.
And now by paying providers,
they train a model for, you
know, months and then all you're
doing is using it as inference.
They've done the training and
they're recouping the cost from
that through, you know,
subscription model or pay as you
go through the inference.
Whereas in CFD we're basically
saying you have to do the
training with your own data.
The future is could there be a
way of a company pretraining a model, then you just do
inference.
But and I'm, I, I will
definitely do a more of a deep
dive on this.
And hopefully if you look in
season 1, I've spoke to, you
know, 3 or 4 top ML people that,
you know, I think they largely
agree that this is a super
exciting space.
But there's still many questions
and uncertainties around
including physics, not including
physics.
And I go back to the statement
that I just don't think the
methods out today are the ones
that we will use.
But the breakthrough moment
could be any time.
And that's why I think it's such
a super exciting space.
So, so the second one is AI/ML.
And of course, why do I mention
AI/ML?
Because it's linked.
The first AI/ML needs GPUs and as
a company if you're being asked
to train ML models then GPU is
the only way to do it and
therefore it makes double the
sense to procure a GPU type
cluster or predominantly GPU
cluster because it can be used
for your ML and your CFD.
Now the third one, which again
in I believe takes its evidence
from these first 2 is cloud
computing or SaaS-type products.
And again, I have to be, you
know, honest I, I'm clearly
working for a cloud computing
company, but my belief is
independent of working for, for
for that company.
And I think, and I hopefully I
can give some evidence to back
that up.
The reason I'm saying this is it
is undeniably true that the
hyperscalers have huge
investments in compute and are
able to give access to compute
that most companies may not be
able to get at the size that
they want and the frequency and
the access and the variety.
And now there may be times when
there's a mixture of the two.
And again, it's an evolving
thing.
If you already have, you know, a
lot of on-premises work, then maybe
the cloud for you is a sort of a
burst option or you know, a
backup option, or it could be a
primary option.
There's, you know, there's
different, different models and
this will evolve over time.
But the fact that major, major
companies around the world are
moving to the cloud because the
way they see it is less of a
what's the cost of the compute,
what's the cost of the hardware,
but more what can people do with
it?
The point being is that there's
a lot of the biggest
misconception of the cloud is
that it's just servers to rent.
That's maybe the way it was 10
years ago.
But now there's so many high
level services added by all the
cloud providers that actually
offering is not only to access
the compute, but many services
that makes it easier to do
things, whether it's machine
learning, whether it's, you
know, high performance computing
or whether it's databases or
virtual or end user computing,
many, many, many things that
makes it easier for your end
users to do stuff or for your
sort of IT teams to do things
that they would have to have
spent more time doing.
So it's making them more
efficient.
So often when people look at a
sort of a cost thing, the cost
only really works when you take
the value of doing everything.
And that's why many, many
companies are driving this.
And the reality of what I've
seen at least is the top down is
really pushing this.
So the CIOs driving this.
And so it's becoming, you know,
a reality for many, many
companies.
But like one and two cloud for
many companies is still a
journey.
And so they're not fully moving
to it.
But the reason it it's appealing
is because if you want to get
access to quite a different
number of GPUs or you want to
test out new GPUs, the reality
is it's probably the easiest
thing.
If you want to go and test GPU,
it's probably easy just to, you
know, get an account on a cloud
provider and do some testing.
Now, of course there are
challenges sometimes with
capacity and things like that,
but that's more that I guess a
transient effect.
Given the still the things of
COVID and and supply chains, it
makes sense to procure it
through a, through a cloud
system.
And you're seeing that, you
know, with, with most companies.
Now, the reason I'm sort of
linking that to the others is
there was also a time when many
of the ISVs and companies
start-ups said, oh, the cloud,
you know, it's just a fad.
But now many of them have turned
around because they see it as an
easier way of delivering their
software to you.
And this is where the SaaS comes
in, software as a service.
Now we're used to software as a
service because many
applications we use through an
app, we don't, we just go to a
website and we use it.
That is software as a service.
So, you know, one option used to
be that you would download and
install something on your
computer or you can go on to
something like, you know, Overleaf I use for like writing
papers.
It's a web-based platform where
you can write LaTeX documents
and it's all stored there in the
cloud.
You don't have to download
anything locally.
Now that makes it a much easier,
nicer experience and it gives
access to everything without you
having to have it.
The analogy would be for the CFD
side is the current way of doing
it is you would take a piece of
software, a binary, let's say,
or open source and you get the
software from them, but you have
to do all the the hardware.
So you wouldn't store it on your
local computer, on your
hardware.
But then what if you want a
bigger computer?
What if you need more memory?
Well, you'd have to have to go
and buy a bigger computer.
What if instead you could go
through some website, access
that same CFD software or some,
you know, through website or
application, and it sorted out
the compute for you.
So you just ran the simulation
and in the back end it was
provisioning a bigger GPU or a
bigger CPU, depending on what
you.
You never needed to worry about
that.
That is the value of the SaaS and
it links to the cloud because
they're all running on the
cloud.
So it gives the cloud gives
those companies the ability that
they don't need to go and buy
data centres, They don't need to
go and buy a compute.
They can just pay a cloud
provider.
And so you are are getting that
and they're using the cloud.
And that's essentially how most
the two ways that we see and I
see of using the cloud, you can
either use the cloud and it's
essentially just a mechanism to
get compute in a in a remote
fashion.
And you don't really notice it.
You just SSH onto a machine.
You don't know whether it's in
your cloud account or where it's
in some physical data centre
that you own.
And of course you can use high
level services.
And the advantage of that one is
you keep everything, let's say
in your account.
So you have a native account,
all your data's in there.
You're a big enterprise, but you
have to know how to use AWS,
You have to know how to do all
the cloud.
The alternative option is you
just say, well, I want to use
ISV software.
A that's just, I'm going to say,
let's say, you know, STAR-CCM+
has a SaaS-like, you know, a
version, you can just go in and
then use that or could be any
other ISV.
I'm just using it as an example.
You can go in and pick the
platform that you want, the
compute that you want go in and
they provision it for you.
And so you've not had to know
any AWS knowledge to get access
to that compute that is going to
become more and more the
mechanism. Look at Luminary Cloud—cloud is in the offering,
right.
They are a cloud first provider
of CFD with the exact thing I
just said that it makes it
easier for you to run stuff
without having to worry about
the compute.
There are many of like SimScale
or Flexcompute or there's,
there's more and more, whether
it's startup or an ISV that are
offering cloud-based backend.
And that's why it's can be, in
my mind, a very positive thing
because it's also, let's say,
forget about the commercials.
if you have an academic code.
If you want someone to use your
code or to give access to it,
actually it might be great if
you build your own sort of SaaS platform, you can give people
access to your code or
collaborate.
And it could be private.
Remember, it doesn't have to be
fully public.
You could just do it through a
username password and they log
on and you can collaborate.
There are many sort of openings
to this that haven't been fully
realized.
People can create codes and
products and serve them to
people without being a sort of
delivering a CD to someone, you
know, that they have to install
on the computer, the cloud we
use everyday.
And it, it is a way of
delivering things to you,
software to you that CFD has to
date not fully embraced.
But that is something a bit like
GPUs and AI/ML, which will only
increase.
And I personally think it's a
good thing and it's something
that you can explore yourself as
again, not saying that people
buying their own desktops or
their own data centers is going
to stop.
Of course it's going to
continue, but I think the
percentage and the data bears out that the growth of HPC for
the cloud is something like 15%
year over year, whereas HPC
on-premises like 8%.
And I think that's Hyperion
third party analyst.
The data shows it is growing.
And so yeah, in this episode
it's more making you aware of
the trends.
Whether you agree with them or
not doesn't really matter.
It's it's they are in my opinion
anyway, the trends that that are
emerging now.
What do these three things mean?
GPU technology, AI/ML, cloud.
In my mind, it means that
companies can move to higher
fidelity transient methods.
Or if your use case doesn't
allow you to do, let's say you
know, scale resolving type
simulation, it could just mean
bigger meshes.
If it's still steady state it,
it could mean running the
simulation for longer, converging to an even tighter tolerance.
It could use more equations for
your chemistry model.
You know more physics in it.
As soon as you have faster, more
compute and access to more of
it, let's say through a cloud
like platform, you are going to
see more use of it.
And why does this matter?
Because ultimately it's about
accuracy.
The biggest problem for CFD and
trust for CFD by very senior people in companies or
by academic research is, is
accuracy compared to physical
testing, right.
That's always going to be the
put down.
The CFD looks good, but how
accurate is it?
Well, as we all know, accuracy
is heavily linked to compute.
And that's why I think this
really will set up a new wave of
move to digital certification.
Digital certification, or
certification by analysis has
long been a goal for aircraft
and.
Car companies in any industry,
but I would argue that compute
and the method you can use is a
limiting factor.
Well, once the compute starts to
become relaxed, the methods you
can use better methods, which
gives you more accuracy and
gives you more evidence to do
less physical testing or even if
you do the same physical
testing, just more virtual
testing.
And that will deliver, in my
opinion, return on investment
because companies can shorten
that time to release a product
or science can be done at an
even greater scale.
So, you know, DNS can be done at
much better resolutions; large-eddy simulations can be done for more
realistic problems.
You can add more, you know,
multi physics modelling inside a case because you have more
compute, you can do multi
physics, so many more things.
So I think whether it's more
physics or just simply things
like smaller time steps, larger meshes, all of this will mean more
accuracy and I really do think
that is going to drive greater
use of CFD and CAE.
So I think those markets are
only going to increase because of the adoption of one, two and three.
This is not in my opinion
static.
This is a growing and will
continue to grow because its
value to a business will be
beyond just pretty pictures and
actually meaningful improvements
in, in, in design and making
things safer, hopefully safe and
faster better than the usual
metrics.
So what's my final fifth point
to this is this means in my mind
mergers and acquisitions, which
is sort of interesting.
And again, it's a slightly more
commercial angle, but I think
this is interesting for any
people who are looking to fund startups or you know, people
interested in the space.
Whenever you have disruptive
technologies like this, whenever
you have the option of new tech,
new hardware, the emergence of
AI/ML, the emergence of SaaS
provisioning and high-fidelity transient
methods, it means it's perfect
time for start-ups and we are
seeing the start-ups.
Why now in the past two years
why didn't we see you know,
Luminary Cloud, Volcano Platforms or
Flexcompute, et cetera, five to seven
years ago?
Because I believe because of the
GPU technology, because of the
cloud it it's set the right
environment.
Why are we seeing 10 start-ups
now with AI/ML methods?
Well, part of it is the
technology, but it's also the
environment because of the huge
generative
AI boom that's giving reason for
these VCs to fund these sort of
companies.
Well, as soon as you have lots
and lots of startups and lots of
main players who own majority of
the market, that means there's
going to be mergers and
acquisitions.
For sure.
The big companies will acquire
the smaller companies to keep
market, but there is always the
potential for a disruptor that a
company does not just get bought
out but actually rises to really
challenge these companies.
I don't know which one it is
because, to date, you know the
large companies like Cadence and
Synopsys, the big EDA companies
and people don't know EDA is
probably even bigger market than
than CAE.
They bought in to those.
So you know Cadence have
acquired a number of companies,
Synopsys have acquired Ansys and
Ansys have acquired a number of
companies, Siemens obviously
Dassault Systèmes.
So you have these players who
see the bigger picture, which is
the digital certification, which
is the digital twins, which is
the, so the way that it can
retransform manufacturing and
the engineering space.
And for them, they see that
simulation is a key bit of this.
And this is really the, the sort
of the big picture that there is
A, it's a fantastic time in my
opinion, to be in CFD; and B, it's
a fantastic time because there
is real value that can be
created.
And the dream of someone sat
there and, you know, virtually
designing something and testing
it and seeing it in like a, you
know, through some sort of
virtual glasses.
It seems to be on the horizon.
So I think the next 5-10 years
we'll see two things.
One, people doing the same
they've always done.
But that's the honest truth, it doesn't
matter.
There are some companies doing
the same sort of modelling they
did 10 years ago.
And fine, if there is all this new
technology that's nice, but I'm
just going to keep doing it the
way I'm going to do it.
For some that will happen, but I
think for others there will be a
dramatic change, an acceleration
and, and I think this is only a
good thing.
So that was my five main trends.
I would love to know whether you
agree.
It is totally just an opinion.
I'm sure I've missed many things
out and I'm happy to go into
more details and other things
and be corrected if I was wrong
in some way. But I hope you found this
interesting and it's got your brain, you
know, thinking of does this
apply to me and my thing is this
just a more niche thing to
certain segments.
But yeah, I hope you enjoyed it.
We've got some great guests
coming up over the next couple
of months, which I'm super
excited by.
So I don't really like to say
this too much, but it apparently
it helps.
So if you are watching this on
YouTube, if you sort of like and
subscribe, it helps the YouTube
algorithms and also lets you
know when there's something.
But also if you're on Spotify,
Apple, you can I think you can
click one of the buttons to to
follow the podcast so that when
something new comes out, you'll
get you'll get notified.
All right, thanks very much.
Hope you enjoyed it.
See you soon.
The.